mientras tus votantes acuden a las urnas
Bosnia y herzegovina se enfrenta más que
nunca al temor por una fragmentación de
su territorio y de sus instituciones
creadas al final de la guerra desde que
terminó el conflicto en 1995 dos
entidades autónomas dividen el país la
federación bosnio croata por un lado y
la República sorpresa dirigida por los
serbios por otro
tres líderes un bosnio un croata y un
serbios se turnan en la jefatura del
estado en cada entidad varios candidatos
se disputan el liderazgo para la
presidencia en el lado serbio
miloradodic líder del partido
nacionalista
smsd se presenta a la presidencia de la
República sorpresa Ultra nacionalista
amenaza regularmente con las sesiones
dejamos Claro que Bosnia ejerce bobina
no es el lugar en el que queremos
permanecer durante mucho tiempo
se presenta a la presidencia del país
pero gran parte de lo que está el juego
en estas elecciones está en el lado
croata
delsco-sitch miembro del centrista
frente democráticos se enfrenta a
borchan a Cristo del partido
nacionalista hdz una formación política
que glorifica a los criminales de guerra
croatas condenados
la ley electoral no ha sido modificada y
estamos discriminados por el hecho de
que otro pueblo El bosnio es más
numeroso en nuestra entidad común por
otro lado el partido bosnio de vaquir y
sed vedovich está jugando la carta del
resentimiento del electorado musulmán
pedimos el apoyo del pueblo estamos ante
las elecciones más importantes desde el
final de la guerra o nos enfrentamos a
la mayor crisis y al mayor problema o
conseguimos el mayor éxito en los
próximos cuatro años a todas estas
tensiones nacionalistas se suma una
aguda crisis económica con una inflación
superior al 15%, y a la salida de
500.000 personas en una década en un
país de poco más de 3 millones de
habitantes